prince william and kate middleton just
released their 2021 christmas card and
yep it's as precious as you think it is
on friday the duke and duchess of
cambridge's social media accounts shared
the new image of the family in the photo
which was taken in jordan william and
kate rest their hands on each other's
knees as they pose with their three kids
eight-year-old prince george
six-year-old princess charlotte and
three-year-old prince louis and get this
the whole fam dressed down for their
holiday pick this year william george
and louie are all wearing polos and
shorts while the ladies chose maxi
dresses now what does it take to get the
perfect family photo well earlier this
week prince william shared a rare
glimpse into his family's morning
routine while speaking on apple fitness
plus's time to walk audio walking series
the duke of cambridge revealed getting
his kids ready for the day is not as
easy as it looks especially with his
older kids george and charlotte who he
says start most mornings with quote a
massive fight about what song is played
how did prince william solve that
problem by simply alternating days for
each child he says quote george gets his
go then charlotte gets her go and
where's prince louis in the mix well
he's just here for the fun prince
william says he joins his older siblings
for their daily dance party quote
charlotte particularly is running around
the kitchen in her dresses and ballet
stuff and everything she goes completely
crazy with louie following her around
trying to do the same thing
but all chaos aside william says quote
it's a really happy moment where the
children just enjoy dancing messing
around and singing so which artists are
making the royal kids playlist shakira
williams says quote one of the songs
that the children are loving at the
moment is shakira wakawaka there's a lot
of hip movements going along with a lot
of dressing up
[Music]
following the interview shakira shared
her reaction on twitter writing quote
i'm so pleased you like my music
princess charlotte and with the holidays
coming up many are wondering how the
royals will be spending christmas this
year of course there's still tension
following harry's decision to step back
from his royal duties and his tell-all
interview alongside his wife meghan
markle with oprah winfrey earlier this
year but it may be his grandmother queen
elizabeth bringing him back home to the
uk the 95 year old royal has been
dealing with some health issues after
spending the night in the hospital for
tests and observations back in october
the queen has also not yet met the duke
and duchess of sussex his newborn
daughter lillabet two factors which
royal expert gaity nickel told et might
have harry visiting sooner rather than
later there has been a lot of
speculation that harry would like to
come back and see his family for
christmas obviously there is there is
still a lot of speculation about
familial relationships and i i don't
think certainly by any means things are
all fixed um but of course you know this
is the queen's grandson and she will
want to see harry i'm sure she's going
to be desperate to meet her
great-granddaughter lilly bert who's of
course named after her and to see archie
so i think the hope is that there will
be an opportunity for for some kind of
family reconciliation and i i can't see
them all gathered around the table at
christmas i mean that's a bit optimistic
and ambitious but and you know harry is
going to be very aware of his
grandmother's health he's going to be
very concerned and it's understandable
that he he will want to be coming over
at some point and whether that's on his
own or with his family um to come and
see the queen
you